this morning we take a journey back in time to
the nation's Antebellum Period journalist Kristen
green explores the lives of enslaved people in her
new book The Devil's half acre and it focuses on
the painful Journey resilience and courage of one
woman who left an influential mark on education
in Virginia's capital city trap between a
railroad yard and an interstate highway A
Renewed landscape has unlocked the legacy of
a stolen people I was doing research to learn
more about the slave trading District down here
research that led to one woman whose Story haunted
journalist Kristen green for nearly a decade
I just couldn't forget Mary Lumpkin like once
I learned about her I thought her story was so
important and needed to be shared on assignment
in 2011 for the Richmond Times Dispatch green
reported on the very place that enslaved woman
lived the nation's largest African-American burial
ground a final resting place for some two hundred
thousand it's right next to the grounds of
the jailhouse known as the devil's half acre
it's here buried under the cobblestones under 15
feet of fill dirt they tore down the building and
covered it up only the foundations remain and
covered up the history too yeah they tried to
erase it that slave industry earned Richmond
the nickname Wall Street of the south after
the transatlantic slave trade ended in 1808. a
domestic slave trade that was already in place
became more apparent jails emerged because people
needed somewhere to keep these enslaved people
prior to sale before they could be put together
in a coffel and marched to the Lower South this
slave jail was owned and operated by Trader
Robert Lumpkin Robert Lumpkin was known for
being incredibly evil incredibly violent not only
did he hold enslaved people in his jail but he
also offered to punish them essentially torture
them for a fee he owned Mary too imprisoned her
here and fathered her five children the first
she bore at the age of 13. there were so many
interviews with enslaved people that echoed
you know her experiences so many enslaved
women recounting being sexually abused by their
owners and so I was able to use the documentation
of experiences of other enslaved women to be able
to weave that into what her experiences were like
so many Mary Lumpkin survived and one year after
the Civil War ended Robert Lumpkin died leaving
everything to the woman quote who resides with
me she had ensured that her kids were educated
she had ensured that they were freed she had freed
herself and that she had later inherited this jail
this violent place and enabled it to become one
of America's first hbcus that's because by 1867
she leased the old jail to baptist Minister Dr
Nathaniel Colver who turned it into a religious
school for newly free black people the devil's
half acre then became God's half acre and by
1899 something more Virginia Union University
just a few miles down the road our founding
mother Mary lumpkins represents for us what it
means to experience America today as president
of vuu Dr Hakeem Lucas recognized Lumpkin with
this Cornerstone and named a street in her honor
to allow her Legacy to be known for providing
a jail as a place for education and empowerment
is the story that we're constantly shaping for
our students over the last two decades activists
have launched the restoration efforts of a burial
ground and slave Trail one that retraces the force
migration into the Deep South this is a part of a
two and a half mile Trail Virginia State Delegate
Dolores mcquinn has been its Steward keeping
Mary's gift in perspective the first elected
African-American Governor came out there we have
Mayors we have leaders and pastors men and women
who also went through Virginia Union Universe
including myself for green connecting the long
lost branches of the Lumpkin family tree was
a challenge because so many had escaped racism
through the generations by denying their
Birthright all I had was descendants who
didn't know anything about her and um who couldn't
necessarily connect to her story because they had
lived as white but then just before finishing her
book green found Dr Cara Olivia Herron lumpkin's
great-great-granddaughter and while she takes
pride in one ancestor she arms herself against
the shame she feels for the other I hate the fact
that I'm his descendant and I went to the house
of musical Traditions to come apart DC Maryland
and brought this to where as a way of protesters
anger I had to put the anger somewhere and this
is why I wore this for green it comes down to
the common Humanity we all share one that in her
book she links back to Mary Lumpkin before she was
anything else Mary Lumpkin was someone's daughter
before she was the mother of a slave Trader's
children and a woman seeking freedom for herself
and her descendants she was an innocent baby girl
a lot to unpack in that book you know so many
contradictions how this enslaver this cruel
enslaver as so much was written about him
could hand over his fortune to the woman who
lived with him as his concubine he must have
felt something for her but the question is
what was it that she felt for him you know
we deal with this today it was fascinating
it's fascinating to me Michelle that you have
a place that was you know physically imprisoned
people that is a place now where you free your
mind for Education absolutely and what that has
brought to so many since yeah it has brought
quite a bit I mean Governor Doug Wilder who
then went on to Howard University law school
then became this amazing footnote to history
is is the first black governor in the United
States elected in this country and how she
was able to go back and just unwind all this
yeah yeah and investigates pretty fascinating
yeah ancestry.com played a bit as well well that
thank you ancestry.com thanks Michelle great story